puis après on a les sujets évidemment
d'accords commerciaux alors je dis pas
que tous les accords commerciaux sont
remett en cause mais enfin il faut quand
même qu'on regarde les contenus celui
qui défrait la chronique en ce moment
c'est plutôt le le Mercosur dont on sait
que ce qui gêne dedans c'est les 99000
tonnes de viande bovine supplémentaire
qui r je dis supplémentaire parce qu'il
en rend déjà près de 300000 tonnes donc
voilà je et le sujet c'est pas
d'importer de la viande bovine là aussi
je voudrais qu'on soit précis je lis
beaucoup de de de contevérité le sujet
c'est comment c'est produit
voilà on a du mal à comprendre queun
élevage moyen français de viande bovine
qui est d'environ 80 vache alors plus la
suite he les gunis c'est voilà soit
comparé à un fidelot sergentin ou
brésilien je vous invite à aller voir un
jour si vous êtes dans ces pays c'est
entre 3000 et 5000 animaux c'est c'est
voilà c'est c'est c'est des sujets de
décarbonation importé pas
systématiquement mais ça mais ça
peut-être voilà donc c'est ça qui a qui
a derrière par ailleurs on peut aussi
avoir des intérêts offensifs sur le
Mercosur je je ne le N pas j'ai essayé
de le dire tout à l'heure